The bioperoid pathway, so this river, the MTHFR, through the folate pathway, feeds the
methionine cycle to make saline, which then feeds the transolpheration pathway, to get rid
of sulfates, sulfites to make sure you're not making excess ammonia, to get rid of ammonia,
to get rid of reactive oxygen species, reactive nitrogen species, that's your glutathione,
that's your SOD, all those things, that also feeds the bioperoid pathway.
The bioperoid pathway is where you make your neurotransmitters, kind of important when you're talking
about mood issues.
Though I know nobody has mood issues here, but we still have to go over this.
So what does your mood come from?
Well, does it come from things that you think about all day?
Yeah, it does, right?
But so there is, when we talk about your brain, there's a chemical component, and that's
what we're going to talk about with the genetics, and there's a neurological component,
and that's what we talk about when I do a lecture on functional neurology.
So when you're dealing with a live patient, or a person with brain cancer, you have to
rebuild these pathways, so they have inflammation in the brain, or when you're talking about
Alzheimer's, or a dementia.
So you're dealing with inflammation in the brain.
So when I have inflammation in the brain, it's going to physically affect the neurological
pathways.
It's also going to chemically affect these metabolic pathways that we're going to talk about.
So the neurological pathways are the physical neurons.
The life prefrontal cortex has to connect with other parts of the brain.
Prefrontal cortex is my part of the brain that makes me human.
So this is where logic comes in, this is where I'm thinking, this is where I'm calculating,
this is where speech comes in.
My dog has a prefrontal cortex, but it's really little.
So I can tell her to set, and she can learn the set because she does have a prefrontal cortex.
But if another dog is running over there, her prefrontal cortex is not large enough to override
what the midbrain is telling her, the archaeocortex, the deep part of the brain.
That's your instinctual part of the brain.
That functions outside of a reason many times.
She wants to obey.
She loves me dearly, but her archaeocortex is sensing she needs to protect.
So she's going to jump up and bark.
And I have to go physically grab her and drag her back, because her prefrontal cortex is
too small.
Her archaeocortex, her instinctual brain, is taking over.
Yes.
It's true for some humans too.
So as a human, we have a larger physical prefrontal cortex.
But when we have inflammation in the brain from a straight neurological pathway issue, it
can block that communication from a prefrontal cortex to the midbrain.
And I started doing things that are beyond reason.
So is it true for patients that was spuddy, but is absolutely true for patients?
So patients that have behavioral issues have typically an neurological problem, physically
neurological problem, and it can be caused from inflammation, it can cause by disuse, it can
cause for everything.
And they have a chemical problem, which we're going to talk about in a second.
So neurological problem can happen because of inflammation, because of a chronic life
or something like that.
But it can happen because of disuse, it can happen because the pathway was never created.
That's what discipline in your child is.
It's created a neurological pathway.
So if you don't discipline your child and tell them, no, you can't do that.
How are they ever supposed to know that they can't do that?
That's education.
If my dog can learn not to go on the neck, my grand kid can learn not to go on the neck.
Following?
That's brain-based therapy, but you fire a pathway, that's brain-based therapy.
When I learned calculus in high school, that was brain-based therapy.
I fired a pathway that didn't exist, I didn't know what the teacher was talking about.
That's what you're doing today, you don't know anything like this.
And if I'm doing a good job teaching you, oh, I get it, and you'll be related to things
that you know about, now that pathway is starting to form.
And I understand that pathway in your brain for genetics is just a gravel road right now.
And maybe it's a two-lane highway because I've been doing this a long time, but if you get
into this and learn and learn and learn, no matter what it is you're going to do, I'm not
asking you to get into this.
It becomes a two-lane highway, in a four-lane highway.
It's a job that you've done for years, you're an expert at accounting, you're an expert at
whatever you're an expert at, you're an expert at it because you fire that pathway over and
over and over and over.
The more you use it, the more it builds.
As long as you have the nutrients to build that pathway, you have everything else in place.
Did you get rid of the biochemistry?
Oh, well, you have issues with that pathway.
So this person, they could remember things their whole life, they were a attorney, they
remember all these case things, and now they have this rapid onset dementia.
Why?
Well, the pathway was there, but they have some source of inflammation, maybe blow it out
the pathway, or end, or some sort of chemical imbalance, loss of chemistry.
So the normal transmitters are being created.
Following me, so I like it to a highway system, my frontal lobe's relocation to my midbrain
is the highway.
I get live disease, I get all this inflammation to my brain, or I get a cushioned, I get
inflammation to my brain, or whatever's causing it.
It's like a flood.
What's a flood do?
No, a highway.
It can wash it out.
How do I get to rebuild it?
You've got to get rid of the flood waters.
It's like, one of my questions about your take exam, are you willing to make strict
dietary changes?
If you check, though, you are not going to be my patient.
If you won't get rid of gluten, you have an eight-year-old kid with 80-80 HD, they won't
stop eating gluten, dairy, good luck with that one, you're ever going to help them.
You've got this constant flood.
You need a brain-based air if you tell you ice-turned-green, but you've got this constant
flood.
You're going to build up the pathway.
It's like building a road back, again, the flood just continued, you'd ever deal with
the flood.
You had to get the water down, okay?
The biopter and pathway is the chemistry of that.
So when we look at this, this is the biopter and pathway.
Ethyl tetrahydrofolate comes in here and pushes this initial pathway.
These are amino acids that feed the production of dopamine, nor up an effort, up an effort
and serotonin.
Those who are made during transmitters and your brain.
So the genes that we look at are the genes that hold those in place in your brain or
degrade them.
The first one is the M-A-O-A gene that degrades serotonin.
So this person has a double allele defect of that gene.
They're going to have excess serotonin.
If they are having a diet that is full of fetalality and tyrosy to try to have, they're really
going to push this pathway.
They don't get rid of serotonin.
They're making excess because they're eating all protein all day.
So here's a seven-year-old kid with 888 HD.
All he'll eat is pizza and chicken nuggets.
I can't get him 880 tails.
Okay.
You're a crappy mother.
No.
He'll say.
I don't care.
Just kidding.
Okay.
So check your front-to-low communication with that because you have to be a parent.
You cannot feed this kid all protein all day because all you're doing is feeding excess
dopamine in excess serotonin.
If they have defects in the comp gene, in the M-A-O gene, you can't get rid of it.
I feel sorry for the kid.
His brain is just roaring.
He can't stop.
He can't settle down.
Dopamine is just like crazy in this kid.
You could argue, well, this way this kid is made, he really shouldn't be sitting in
school.
And there's logic there.
If you do have comp gene defects and bomb gene defects, it's going to be very difficult to
sit in school and behave.
It'll make the teacher look at the board and stop looking outside and stop looking at the
squirrel.
However, it is what it is and we can do some neural and some chemical adjustments to help decrease
dopamine in serotonin excess production.
Following?
So we're going to take this kid.
This person has defects like that and you're going to cut them way back on protein.
We have to look at the other genes too, it's typically with these really bad cases with
kids with ADDU and he's in a huge amount of histamine.
Huge amounts of gut inflammation equals brain inflammation.
You've got a meal with a gut, absolutely, you've got a meal with a diet where I said I
wouldn't take them and then you have to look at this question back there.
So why is the typical treatment an upper?
Because kids' brains react differently to medication than adult brains do.
There's a metabolic pathway that I can't remember for that, but if you give a kid a kid, for
instance if you give a kid a fluoride, fluoride is going to be an upper for a child, it's going
to be a downer for an adult.
It's going to cause depression and adults, it's going to cause excitation in a child,
in their brain.
Right, not this, so this is how you make it or degrade it.
The drugs have different effects on children.
Good question.
Does that make sense?
Still with me?
So it is, okay, let's say I'm not a child and I have some issues and I have, this is my
gene profile.
I'm looking at mine and I have a double allele mound effect and I have all these comp defects.
The wonder I have so much anxiety, a lot of serotonin, a lot of don't remain an adult who
has a healthy front along, still going to have symptoms of anxiety, OCD, you know, quick
tempered, ask your spouse, easily agitated, get angry, easy, probably watching too much
Fox News, but I don't know, but yeah, you probably are, you have to do a look at what
you're feeding yourself evolutionally too, right, and there's things from a spiritual standpoint
that you have to do, but I have good spiritual people that are saying I'm trying to hold every
cock captive and I feel like I'm going crazy, you have to look at big brain chemistry, so
this is the way you could look at brain chemistry and understand you could do a neurotransmitter
assessment too and look at the levels of neurotransmitter, but remember those are going to be a photograph
of a boolean train, you almost have to do multiple pictures of that because that's going to change
throughout the day upon debate, following me, so from a chemical side, how would you intervene
with a patient like this, you'd cut down on their proteins and there's some specific nutrition
that you could address as well, and we get into the next, gee, you know, this is the, this
is the neurotransmitter profile that you could run as well, I also wrote a paper on cup
in my pathway, GDFX, that talks about kind of what I just talked about, it's available
on the other website as well. This is the NOSG right there that we talked about, but I don't
think I show the slide when we talk about the NOSG, but that's in the biopterid pathway
and when I have DFX in this, gee, if I have excess free or what's called uncoupled nitric oxide
synthase, and that's what could bond to the excess super oxide ion, would I have super oxide
that's what tastes DFX?